we're going to turn now to a topic that
is getting new attention right now
because of the war in ukraine the plight
of the refugees an oscar-nominated
documentary from denmark is using
animation to share the struggles that
they face the movies call flee the
director is jonas poer rasmussen tells
the story of his friend's journey
immigrating from afghanistan as a
teenager the film has made oscar history
with one two three nominations for best
documentary thank you very much best
animated feature and best international
film you go giannis in this clip the
refugee his name is amin his mother and
brother are about to embark on a
dangerous boat trip across the baltic
sea to sweden
foreign
we are joined now by flea's director his
name is jonas par power rather rasmussen
rasmussen congratulations to you thank
you so much really it's so good i have i
have to confess when i first heard okay
documentary animation i don't know and
subtitles i don't know
i'm telling you it is so good it's so
well done it's beautifully told and
after a while you just forget that
you're reading that's how great the
story was in your storytelling so bravo
to you but take us to amine how you two
met you all were teenagers how did you
meet and what stood out to you about him
but you know um i grew up in this very
small rural danish village and one day
on the train he was there um
and he was very you know fashionably
dressed and people in that area didn't
really care about fashion so he stood
out in the crowd right away and i just
thought to myself man that that guy who
was this guy yeah and i wanted to know
him um
but he didn't tell you about his life no
he didn't yeah you know we went up every
morning at the bus stop going to high
school uh and i was of course curious
about how and why he came
but he didn't want to talk about it and
that's 25 years ago now and then he's
finally nine years ago started to open
up about his past yeah and you've
decided to make the story animated you
could have done a traditional
documentary
talk to us about that decision and what
it allowed you to do
one thing was that he wanted to be
anonymous because what he did what you
hear in the film is his real voice
telling the story for the very first
time and it's not easy for him to talk
about so the fact that he could be
anonymous and didn't have to be in the
public eye with the story was was really
what enabled him to start to open up
but then it's also
you know because most of the story takes
place in the past so
how do you make the past come back alive
and here animation was really good tool
to do that but and also you know sort of
the audience sees this family struggle
to get money to safely travel to a new
country while also evading law
enforcement and i just thought wow that
is that is happening today right now as
we speak and it sort of really
crystallized for me the struggle and the
plight that people who just want a
better life what they have to go through
to get that life and
we should just be a little bit more
accommodating in understanding that yeah
definitely and and you know in the
beginning this project is really born
from the friendship and my curiosity
about about my friend but then seeing
what's going on now you know i really
hoped that because this story is sold
from the inside of our friendship that i
gave some new ones to these kind of
refugee stories so you could see that
yes he's a refugee but he's so much more
you know he also has hopes and dreams
and ambitions like everyone else yeah
and so we're hearing his regular voice
but in the animation he's laying down
was that a deliberate technique that you
used it is
i have a background in radio uh and when
you do radio of course you don't have an
image so by having him lay down and
close his eyes and talk present sense
it's really a way of making be really
descriptive and and and you get the
sense of presence into his way of
talking in another way how are you
processing that you're nominated for
three oscars from this story that you're
just telling a story about your friend
did that surprise you
you didn't start out thinking i'm gonna
or maybe you did think i'm gonna go for
an oscar here no no no no you know it's
it's it started out a conversation
between me and him just the two of us in
my living room in copenhagen you know
and then from there i just grew and grew
and it's been now it's almost a decade
since we started and and to be here now
and being nominated for three academy
awards is just so it's unreal can i just
ask you about the technique like the
idea of like making it an animated film
but there are scenes where you're using
file footage from afghanistan which when
the first time that happens i thought
wow this is so cool like what made you i
did two players did you think the same
yeah
what made you decide to pick that route
no but i just wanted to make sure that
people understood that this is a real
story that underneath the animation you
have a real person and a real voice to
keep so to keep this authenticity to
have this alcohol footage in there to
kind of remind people that this is a
real story and the reason why he had to
flee is because of historical events
that happened in the world we all belong
to so i wanted to have that throughout
the film you also lay on the layer that
he's gay which was also a very difficult
time for him because in his family
you didn't talk about it in afghanistan
so he has to tell him yeah yeah he had
to tell that part of the story too and
there's some humor that you also use
yeah but i think you know again to kind
of show you know the nuance of it that
that he's a regular person who also
falls in love who also is attracted to
to he's attracted to chocolate fandam
you know there's these kind of light
moments in the film and it's so
important to get that so you see the
nuance of it and you see that refugees
are not just refugees you know they do
they're human beings regular people
we're all we are all descended from
migrants if not migrants ourselves i
mean it's funny how quickly we forget
that yeah we need a movie like this to
remind us yeah
bravo well done well done i can't wait
for the academy awards cheering cheering
you on big time jonas poe rasmussen we
thank you again flea is currently in
select theaters and you can watch in the
comfort in your home of your home it's
streaming on hulu very easy to find it